So, I started small with
theft tools open, so
I'd get the resolution,
and I pulled the page out.
All right, that's about 680 pixels, and
I think this still looks good, so
let's make it a little bit larger.
Here I am at about 815 pixels.
Still, I think that looks good.
I think I can go larger.
Okay, now I'm at 1130.
Okay, this is definitely
way too large for here.
Let's pull it back in a little bit.
Around 850 pixels or so, I think
I'm about at my limit for how wide,
I want this image to be, and for how
far apart I want these elements to be.
So, for my answer I put 850 pixels, but
really like I said this
is an art not a science.
So if you didn't get the same
answer as me that's totally fine.
This isn't the right answer but,
you know, it's what I think.